ya hemos pasado bastante tiempo pensando
en la en lo que son las series de furia
de verdad que básicamente consisten en
tomar una función periódica como nuestra
onda cuadrada y vamos a tratar de
representarla como suma de senos y
cosenos con pesos verdad y algunos dirán
bueno porque a cero podríamos
considerarlo como un seno o un coseno y
en realidad es que a cero lo podemos ver
como a cero por coseno de cero t porque
0 30 coseno de cero es 1 y si está
multiplicando a sub 0 pues entonces nos
queda simplemente a sub 0 por eso es que
es como un coseno con peso muy bien y en
el vídeo anterior empezamos a ver una
fórmula justamente para a sub zero
verdad utilizando digamos las
propiedades que ya hemos visto en muchos
vídeos anteriores verdad pudimos
concluir que a cero se puede calcular
como el promedio el valor promedio de la
función f
a lo largo del período
esta función porque es periódica y de
periodo 2 y en este caso muy bien
entonces azul 0 se puede calcular de
esta forma ahora en lo que lo que quiero
dedicar digamos a ver en este vídeo es a
encontrar una fórmula para a sub n donde
a su vez son los coeficientes que
acompañan a las funciones coseno para
cualquier n arbitraria que sea positiva
es decir n mayor que 0 muy bien esa es
la idea para este vídeo y vamos a
utilizar una técnica similar
ahora vamos a multiplicar ambos lados de
nuestra función aquí teníamos una
expresión de nuestra función con senos
cosenos y el acero a sub zero pero ahora
lo que vamos a hacer es multiplicar de
ambos lados por coseno de nt
multiplicamos de ambos lados por coseno
de nt multiplicamos aquí por coseno de g
mt entonces quizás puedas darte cuenta
de a dónde vamos a llegar con todo esto
verdad porque digamos si tienes muy en
mente todas las propiedades que ya hemos
estado verificando en vídeos anteriores
verás más o menos cuál va a ser el
procedimiento a seguir entonces una vez
que hemos multiplicado por coseno de nt
de ambos lados ahora lo que vamos a
hacer es integrar sobre el intervalo 0 2
pie entonces integramos en el intervalo
0 2 y por supuesto con respecto a t y
aquí de una vez voy a sacar las
constantes muy bien aquí es integral de
0 a 2 pi con respecto de t integral de 0
a 2 pi con respecto de verdad por
supuesto sacamos las con las constantes
de la integral e integral de 0 a 2 pican
respecto de t
ya me estoy cansando muy bien tenemos la
integral de 02 pi con respecto a t
integral de 0
con respecto a t ya casi acabamos
integral de 0 a 2 pi con respecto a t
integral de 0 a 2 y con respecto a t y
esto fue bastante divertido pero ya
terminamos muy bien tenemos esta
integral y ahora vamos a ver cómo es que
todo esto se simplifica vamos a utilizar
las propiedades que ya teníamos
anteriormente integral de seno y cosenos
es 0 verdad de estos senos y cosenos
para m al arbitrario verdad que se
enteró para el seno m tendría que ser no
nulo para el caso del coseno y sabemos
que el integral del seno por coseno
verdad no importando que que enteros
estemos considerando es 0 y la integral
del producto de cosenos es 0 siempre y
cuando sean distintos verdad entonces
vamos a ver eso aquí aquí tenemos
justamente la integral del cose no de un
múltiplo de t entonces éstos
y vale 0 acá tenemos la integral de
producto de cos en los que cuando son
distintos los enteros que multiplican
pues vale 0 aquí tenemos la integral del
producto de seno y coseno eso siempre
valen 0 la integral del producto y
cosenos eso es valen 0 cuando no se
tiene la misma el mismo coeficiente
digamos con el mismo valor de n que
acompaña t otra vez integral del
producto diseño y coseno todos estos se
anulan excepto este de aquí verdad
porque cuando coincide digamos el valor
de n con el que ya teníamos
anteriormente en esta parte amarilla
pues nos quedaría coseno cuadrado de nt
verdad y nosotros sabemos que la
integral del coseno cuadrado de mt
cuando cuando es un entero que
multiplica t verdad e integramos esto
nos debe dar pi cuando el entero es un
entero no nulo y aquí justamente tenemos
ese caso así que esto de aquí todo esto
que tenemos en este integral
y todo esto vale así que vamos a vamos a
reescribir lo del lado derecho
tendríamos a n por mi verdad porque
todos los demás términos se cancelan y
esto tendrá que ser igual tendrá que ser
igual a lo que tenemos del lado
izquierdo que es la integral de 0 a 2 pi
de nuestra función
efe dt ft multiplicada por el coseno de
deporte y estamos integrando con
respecto a t
así que de aquí es muy fácil despejar
quien es a n esto simplemente será 1 /
pi que multiplica a la integral de 0 a 2
pi verdad a la integral de 0 a 2 pie de
ft
x coseno de nt y por supuesto integramos
con respecto a t entonces en resumen si
nosotros queremos saber quién es el
coeficiente a sub n simplemente
multiplicamos a la función por coseno de
nt integramos de 0 a 2 pi y luego
dividimos entre pi es bastante simple
verdad esto es lo genial de todo este
proceso así que espero que hayas
disfrutado este vídeo tanto como yo